Hillary versus Bernie the
mayweather-pacquiao of politics and a
distraction that helps us momentarily
forget the other side is still undecided
on science even though the two Democrats
have their differences sometimes it
sounds like they're saying the same
thing but how much of what they're
saying really is the same it's hurt the
great compromiser versus him the
uncompromising the hawk versus the snowy
owl he excites young people she excites
Lena Dunham we need to ask you about
this dress oh please tell us oh grandma
what was it like back in your heyday she
has more sway with voters of color he
has sway with white dreaded lyft drivers
she's raising two billion dollars for
her campaign mostly from super PACs
whereas he is throwing war files or the
house parties bernie sounds like he
believes in what he's saying we have got
to create an economy in america and we
can which works for working families not
just billionaires Hillary sounds like
she can't believe that she's saying
democracy can't just be for billionaires
and corporations so how are the two
actually affecting each other on the
issues on certain topics like gun
control Hillary is making the backwoods
Vermont senator look like mr. Magoo
walking stick but on a lot of other
issues Sanders is pulling Hillary to the
left just for the record are you a
progressive or you're moderate I'm a
progressive but I'm a progressive who
likes to get things done first order of
business get elected president but it
has been a bit of a progressive
coming-out party for Hillary she came
out against the Keystone XL pipeline and
came out against the free trade deal
called the TPP though she took her time
to evolve on the issues ie seeing what
Bernie was up to her newfound opposition
to the TPP has probably been super
awkward with her longtime advisor
vice-chairman of Morgan Stanley the
investment firm that donated half a
million dollars to her previous
campaigns and has given nine million
dollars to lobby for the TPP ooh see in
this race no one wants to be seen as the
capitalist do I consider myself part of
the casino capitalist process by which
so few have so much and so many have so
little no I don't I believe in a society
where all people throughout that's just
I have folks with us
especially not Hillary is there any bill
anybody else on the stage who's not a
capitalist well let let me just follow
up on that Anderson if I could just ride
that applause Anderson - frontrunners
have different approaches to handling
Wall Street Bernie says break up the big
banks and tax speculation Hillary a
former Wall Street lawyer has a more
tempered approach I basically said cut
it out and don't let it happen again
that's probably because if you wanted to
look deeper and I'm not saying you do
but if you did you might learn that
Hillary's already gotten at least half a
million dollars in campaign money from
Wall Street people running banks like
these
and it's hard to bite the hand that
feeds you maybe just nibble at it once
or twice now of course if it weren't for
social movements Democrats wouldn't even
be talking about these issues and Bernie
wouldn't just look like your Gramps he'd
be about as relevant as him but these
differences run pretty deep especially
for a Democratic Party that over the
years has moved to the right like a
tinder swipe you'll regret forever now
does any of this matter when Republicans
are still debating the concept of
government itself not totally sure yet
it's just better to buy candidates
darling Clinton Bush Trump wife brother
racist uncle-in-law after one too many